welcome to support vector machine a lot
of times referred to as the SVM
algorithm my name is Richard Kirchner
I'm with simply learned before we dive
into the SVM let's take a look at
applications of the support vector
machine at least some general ones that
are commonly used with it face detection
text in hypertext categorization
classification of images and
bioinformatics these are only about a
few of those that are used with this SVM
as we go through this lesson see if we
can figure out what other ones you could
apply it to and also what you would want
to use some other tools for what's in it
for you today we're gonna cover about
six different sections we're gonna start
with what is machine learning so we can
see where the vector machine fits in why
the support vector machine what is a
support vector machine and understanding
the support vector machine once we go
through an understanding of how it works
and what it looks like we're gonna look
at the advantages of support vector
machine and finally dive into a use case
in Python will write some script on it
let's start with what is machine
learning and even more specific where
does a support vector machine algorithm
fit in the biggest split in machine
learning is between the three categories
supervised learning where we have data
we can train it unsupervised learning
where we're just guessing at what we can
make sense of the data and reinforcement
learning where we reinforce it good or
bad behavior since the SVM is specific
to supervised learning machine learning
model learns from the past input data
and makes future predictions as output
so we teach the model we teach it what a
strawberry is and once the model is
trained it can identify up strawberry
that's what's mean by supervised
learning in the larger picture of the
machine learning model and under
supervised learning you can see that the
support vector fits in under
classification deciding what yes-and-no
is and there is also a regression
version but it is primarily used for
classification let's take a detour and
see if we can connect us to the human
experience and find out why support
vector machine so in this example last
week my son and I visited a fruit shop
dad is that an apple or a strawberry so
the question comes up what fruit do they
just pick up from the fruit stand after
a couple of seconds you can figure out
that it was
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's why not build a
model which can predict an unknowing
data and in this we're gonna be looking
at some sweet strawberries or crispy
apples we want it to be able to label
those two and decide what the fruit is
and we do that by having data already
put in so we already have a bunch of
strawberries we know our strawberries
and they're already labeled as such we
already have a bunch of apples we know
our apples and are labeled as such then
once we train our model that model then
can be given the new data and the new
data is this image in this case you can
see a question mark on it
and it comes through and goes it's a
strawberry in this case we're using the
support vector machine model SVM is a
supervised learning method that looks at
data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we drawn a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknowing as colorful
and tasty as a fruit example is let's
take a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
gonna start with a set of people with a
different height and a different weight
and to make this work we'll have to have
a sample data set a female where you
have their height weight 174 65 174 88
and so on and we'll need a sample data
set of the male they have a height 179
91 82 80 and so on let's go ahead and
put this on a graph so have a nice
visual so you can see here we have two
groups based on the height versus the
weight and on the left side we're gonna
have the women on the right side we're
gonna have the men now if we're gonna
create a classifier let's add a new data
point and figure out if it's male or
female
so before we can do that we need to
split our data first we can split our
data by choosing any of these lines in
this case we draw in two lines
through the data in the middle that
separates the men from the women but to
predict the gender of a new data point
we should split the data in the best
possible way and we say the best
possible way because this line has a
maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points and the line should
be as far as possible in technical terms
we can say the distance between the
support vector and the hyperplane should
be as far as possible and this is where
the support vectors are the extreme
points in the data set and if you look
at this data set they have circled two
points which seem to be right on the
outskirts of the women and one on the
outskirts of the min and hyperplane has
a maximum distance to the support
vectors of any class now you'll see the
line down the middle and we call this
the hyperplane because when you're
dealing with multiple dimensions it's
really not just a line but a plane of
intersections and you can see here where
the support vectors have been drawn in
dashed lines the math behind this is
very simple we take D plus the shortest
distance to the closest positive point
which would be on the men's side and D
minus is the shortest distance to the
closest negative point which is on the
women's side the sum of D plus and D
minus is called the distance margin or
the distance between the two support
vectors that are shown in the dashed
lines and then by finding the largest
distance margin we can get the optimal
hyperplane once we've created an optimal
hyperplane we can easily see which side
the new data fits in and based on the
hyperplane we can say the new data point
belongs to the male gender hopefully
that's clear and how that works on a
visual level as a data scientist you
should also be asking what happens if
the hyperplane is not optimal if we
select a hyperplane having low margin
then there is a high chance of miss
classification this particular SVM model
the one we discussed so far is also
called or referred to as the lsv
so far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an SVM for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
3-dimensional array using the kernel you
can see we can place a hyperplane right
through it and easily split the data
before we start looking at a programming
example and dive into the script let's
look at the advantage of the support
vector machine
we'll start with high dimensional input
space or sometimes referred to as the
curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension to dimension three
dimension when you get to a thousand
dimensions a lot of problems start
occurring with most algorithms that have
to be adjusted for the SVM automatically
does it in high dimensional space one of
the high dimensional space one high
dimensional space that we work on is
sparse document vectors this is where we
tokenize the words in document so we can
run our machine learning algorithms over
though I've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a specific instance or is gonna be
biased to a higher low value with the
SVM it naturally avoids the overfitting
and bias problems that we see in many
other algorithms these three advantages
of the support vector machine make it a
very powerful tool to add to your
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a use case study
we're actually gonna dive in to some
Python programming and so we're gonna go
into a problem statement and start off
with the zoo so in the zoo example we
have family members going to the zoo we
have the young child going dead is that
a group of crocodiles or alligators well
that's hard to differentiate and zoos
are a great place to start looking at
science and understanding how things
work especially as a young child and so
we can see the parents in here thinking
well what is the difference between a
crocodile and an alligator well one
crocodiles are larger in size alligators
are smaller in size snout width the
crocodiles have a narrow snout and
alligators have a wider snout and the
course in the modern day and age the
father's Hittner is thinking how can I
turn this into a lesson for my son and
he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups I don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example we're not
gonna use actual measurements and data
we're just using that for imagery and
that's very common and a lot of machine
learning algorithms and setting them up
by let's roll up our sleeves and we'll
talk about that more in just a moment as
we break into our Python script so here
we arrive in our actual coding and I'm
gonna move this into a Python editor in
just a moment but let's talk a little
bit about what we're gonna cover first
we're gonna cover in the code the setup
how to actually create our SVM and
you're gonna find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data so we're gonna
create some data I talked about creating
data just a minute ago and so we'll get
into the creating data here and you'll
see this nice correction of our two
blobs and we'll go through that in just
a second and then the second part is
we're gonna take this and we're gonna
bump it up a notch we're gonna show you
what it looks like behind the scenes but
let's start with actually creating our
setup I like to use the Anaconda Jupiter
notebook because it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
Python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda Python notebook or
anaconda Jupiter notebook with Python
we're using Python 3 I believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and you'd have to look at
the SK learn and make sure if you're
using a 2x version or an earlier version
let's go ahead and put our code in there
and one of the things I like about the
Jupiter notebook is I go up to view and
I'm gonna go ahead and toggle the line
numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is that I
did in in this case I'm using Google
Chrome Explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like I said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're gonna import four different
parts the first two I want you to look
at our line 1 and line 2 our numpy as NP
and matt plot library pie plot as p LT
now these are very standardized imports
when you're doing work the first one is
the numbers python we need that because
part of the platform we're using uses
out for the numpy array and i'll talk
about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus a standard python array and
normally it's pretty standard setup to
use NP for numpy the map plot library is
how we're gonna view our data so this
has do you need the NP for the SK learn
module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
SVM but we're gonna put it there so you
have a nice visual aid and we can show
you what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're gonna I'm gonna jump one
ahead to line number four
that's the SK learned dataset samples
generator import and make blobs and I
told you that we were gonna make up data
and this is a tool that's in the SK
learn to make up data I personally don't
want to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
I work on measuring their snouts and
with them lengths instead we're just
gonna make up some data and that's what
that make blobs is it's a wonderful tool
if you're ready to test your your setup
and you're not sure about what data are
gonna put in there you can create this
blob and it makes it real easy to use
and finally we have our actual
svm the SK learn import SVM online 3 so
that covers all our imports we're gonna
create remember I use the make blobs to
create data and we're gonna create a
capital X and a lowercase y equals make
blobs in samples equals 40 so we're
gonna make 40 lines of data it's gonna
have two centers with the random state
equals 20 s which each each groups gonna
have 20 different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under X an XY plane so I have two
numbers under X and Y will be 0 or 1
that's two different centers so we have
yes or no in this case alligator a
crocodile that's what that represents
and then I told you that the actual SK
learn or the SVM is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with CL f
equals SVM dot SVC kernel equals linear
and I sets equal to 1 although in this
example since we are not regulating the
data because we want to be very clear
and easy to see I went ahead you can set
it to a thousand a lot of times but
you're not doing that but for this thing
linear because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
will be a nice linear line instead of a
full plain so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do CL f dot fit x comma y and
that's it CL F has been created and then
we're gonna go ahead and display it and
I'm gonna talk about this display here
in just a second but let me go ahead and
run this code and this is what we've
done is we've created two blobs you'll
see the blue on the side and then kind
of an orangish on the other side that's
our two sets of data they represent one
represents crocodiles and one represents
alligators and then we have our
measurements in this case we have like
the width and length of the snout and I
did say I was gonna come up here and
talk just a little bit about our plot
and you'll see PLT that's what we
imported we're gonna do a scatter plot
that means we're just putting dots on
there and then look at this notation I
have the capital X and then in brackets
I have a colon comma zero that's from
numpy if you did that in a regular array
you'll get an error in a Python array
you have to have that in an umpire ray
it turns out that our make blobs returns
a number array and this notation is
great because what it means is the first
part
the colon means we're going to do all
the rows that's all the data in our blob
we created under capital X and then the
second part has a comma zero we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value we
always start with zero and then one so
we have column zero and column one and
you can look at this as our XY plots the
first one is the X plot and the second
one is the Y plot so the first one is on
the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one XO the one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 going up the left-hand side s equals
30 is just the size of the dot so we can
see them and said real tiny dots and
then the C map equals P LT Cmdr and
you'll also see the C equals y that's
the color we're using two colors 0 1 and
that's why we get the nice blue and the
two different colors for the alligator
and the crocodile now you can see here
that we did this the actual fit was done
in two lines of code a lot of times
they'll be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like -1 and 1 and we reshape it but for
this it's not necessary and it's also
kind of nice because you can actually
see what's going on and then if we
wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case I am giving it a width and
length 3/4 and with the length 5/6 and
note that I put the data as a set of
brackets and then I have the brackets
inside and the reason I do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case I'm processing two lines and
then I'm just going to print and you'll
see CLF predict new data so the CLF and
the dot predict part is gonna give us an
answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the 3/4 is going to be on the
one side and the 5/6 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dig in and see what it's going
behind-the-scenes and let's see what
that looks like so the next step is to
dig in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes and also put that at a
nice pretty graph we're going to spend
more work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and I'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and I'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're gonna go in there
and add in those lines we're gonna see
what those lines look like and how to
set those up and finally we're gonna
plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is a hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're gonna talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
gonna paste that code in and you'll see
that the plot show is moved down below
let's scroll up a little bit and if you
look at the top here of our new section
one two three and four is the same code
we had before and let's go back up here
and take a look at that we're gonna fit
the values on our SVM and then we're
gonna plot scatter it and then we're
gonna do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plots show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
I've done this plot show I have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five I'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals P Ltd CA now right now we're
actually spending a lot of time just
graphing that's all we're doing here
okay so this is how we need to display a
nice graph with our results in our data
ax is very standard note used variable
when you talk about PLT and it's just
setting it to that axes the last axes in
the PLT they can get very confusing if
you're working with many different
layers of data on the same graph and
this makes it very easy to reference the
ax so this reference is looking at the
PLT that we created and we already
mapped out our two blobs on and then we
want to know the limits so we want to
know how big the graph is we can find
out the x limit and the y limit simply
with the get x limit and get y limit
commands which is part of our Met plot
library and then we're going to create a
grid and you'll see down here we have
we've set the variable X X equal to
impede line space X limit 0 X limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the Y space and then we're gonna go
in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers Python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space in the mesh grid we've taken X X
small s X x equals NP line space and we
have our x limits 0 and our x limit 1
and we're gonna create 30 points on it
and we can do the same thing for the
y-axis now this has nothing to do with
our evaluation it's all we're doing is
we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the X limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the Y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
gonna do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 2 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the Y
Y and the X X we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the Y Y coordinates and the X x
coordinates now remember we're working
with num be and Python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being X comma 1 you know X comma Y
and then X 2 comma Y 2 and it's in the
next set of data it would be a column of
X's and a call
of wise and that's what we have here is
we have a column of wise and we put it
as a capital YY and a column of X is
capital X X with all those different
points being listed and finally we get
down to the numpy V stack just as we
created those in the mesh grid we're now
going to put them all into one array X Y
array now that we've created the stack
of data points we're going to do
something interesting here we're going
to create a value Z and the Z equals the
CLF that's our that's our support vector
machine we created then we've already
trained and we have a dot decision
function and we're going to put the XY
in there so here we have all this data
we're gonna put that XY in there that
data and we're gonna reshape it and
you'll see that we have the X X dot
shape in here this literally takes the X
X resets it up connected to the Y and
the Z value lets us know whether it is
the left-hand side is gonna generate
three different values the Z value does
and it'll tell us whether that data is a
support vector to the left the
hyperplane in the middle or the support
vector to the right so it generates
three different values for each of those
points and those points have been
reshaped so that they're right on a line
on those three different lines so we've
set all of our data up we've labeled it
to three different areas and we've
reshaped it and we've just taken 30
points in each direction if you do the
math you have 30 times 30 that's 900
points of data and we separate it
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're gonna create a
contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital X X capital y Y these
have been reshaped to fit those lines z
is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals K
and I told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the Alpha is just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dashed dashed
lines and then a single one is just a
straight line that's what all that setup
does
and then finally we take our ax scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dashed dashed line and the dashed line
on that grid and you can see here when
we do the CLF dot support vectors we are
looking at column zero and column one
and then again we have the s equals 100
so we're gonna make them larger and the
line width equals one face colors equals
none let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dash lines and
they have the NIR data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it course these are
pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth key takeaways
machine learning what is machine
learning we looked at a little bit at
supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning
specifically we're working in supervised
learning
why support vector machine so that we
can classify objects what is support
vector machine where we learned about
the support vectors and the hyperplane
we dug in deeper into understanding
support vector machine for using
multiple data where the data is split
and you had to create new levels or new
planes and finally we did our case study
of crocodiles and alligators where you
got to see hands-on how to do a support
vector machine and what's going on
behind the scenes and how to display
that I want to thank you for joining us
today if you have any questions or any
requests feel free to add that to the
comments at the bottom of the page
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here